[Music]
all right finally holy crap look
pookie's here too yeah
how's it going a problem with the
connection yeah i just couldn't get it i
would you know we had the little video
on that was you know the coming soon
video and it just kept going red orange
red orange red orange and then youtube
just said the connection was poor i
don't know what the [ __ ] problem is
man this internet here is just killing
me so i had to go get my phone and
hook up the mobile hotspot
so hopefully it's working now
yeah
i don't see anybody commenting yet but
it seems to be okay on my end
so hi everybody happy sunday hope your
weekend's been going good so far
i can't believe pookie's been sitting
there like all this time yeah look at
her she's all chill yeah by the way she
found out how to get into and out of the
kit the uh bathroom cabinets i'd caught
her slipping in there today and then i
was like oh no she's gonna be stuck in
there but then she just like came right
back out i was like okay well you can
just
go on in there if you want to that's
what you want to do oh
what did we
all right so what are we what are we
doing we're doing the uh what you call
it yeah i watched a movie on shutter
last night actually because i went over
to shutter because i was gonna watch the
newest uh creep show
and uh that actually the the creep show
that i watched last night was i guess
it's the fourth one season three episode
four um and that was pretty good the
first one was kind of dumb the one that
was like about sirens um
but the second one was actually kind of
a post-apocalyptic
demons or taking over the earth kind of
thing and you had to like behead him and
stuff and that was pretty cool i
actually like the way that one was shot
so then while i was over there because i
mentioned before
that i hadn't really uh caught up with
any of the newer movies that are on
shutter because i've been so busy doing
other things so i just decided to go
ahead and watch one that was on there so
the one that were that uh that i watched
was called the medium
now this one i thought it was originally
just like a thai movie because it is in
uh it's in uh you know whatever it's in
thai right but and it's set in thailand
but i think it's also like a south
korean co-production as well
and i guess it's the same director i
think that did that movie shutter back
in night in 2004 which is actually
really good and i think i was talking
about it on wednesday now that i'm
thinking about it and also
um i think it was the same
you know like the same producer or the
same screenwriter or something like that
as um the whaling from 2016 which is a
great [ __ ] movie so i first said this
has like a really good like horror
pedigree i suppose um you know so i
thought that i would like uh check it
out oh there's my live chat mine's okay
i was like where is everybody yeah
because i wasn't getting anything on top
chat i know yeah i don't know why it's
just because mine doesn't usually go to
top chat automatically it just goes to
live chat but yeah louis says let's hit
the third time is the charm well like i
said we're going through my phone now so
hoping
he's streaming powered by tom's
testosterone yeah yeah i'm just gonna
i'm gonna plug the usb car cord into his
butt
and power it off that
ridiculous
is it is it really any more ridiculous
than uh what you said yeah
bismuth says if you like squid game
watch the platform we've seen the
platform uh we actually did a review of
it like uh quite a while back yeah that
was a while back that was like a
platform was better than squid game so
far if you ask me yeah i'd agree with
that i like squid game but yeah i think
the platform is is better and it does
actually kind of remind me of that this
movie here it does have a little bit of
um you can you can tell that's kind of
like some of the same people that were
involved in the whaling because it kind
of has a similar a little bit of a
similar vibe although i feel like the
whaling had more like funny [ __ ] in it
um
not outright funny but i don't know um
also the length of it uh this movie the
medium is long it's like two and a half
hours it didn't really seem that long
like when i was watching it but just
know that going into it i didn't love it
um
it's good but
and there's like it does some different
things it's a mockumentary like a faux
documentary
um and it's like about a possession you
know and i know there's like a million
of those
but
because it's set in thailand and has
some kind of like uh you know that kind
of that kind of belief system and
there's you know cultural differences
that is actually kind of cool another
thing that i liked about what the story
is is that there's a film crew and
they're going to thailand and they're
doing a documentary about this woman
named nim
who is um a shaman essentially and i
guess
that
her thing was that
there's this goddess what's the goddess
called bayan i think
and she basically like you allow the
goddess to take over your body like
right to be the shaman now i guess the
goddess had initially chose nim's sister
uh whose name is noy i think but noy
didn't want to do it and so then like it
goes to the next one so what ends up
happening over the course of the movie
is that
nim they kind of like start out the
documentary like talking to her and like
you know talking about the beliefs and
about the goddess and how it all
happened and everything how she allowed
the goddess to possess her
but then like weird [ __ ] starts
happening with nim's niece whose name is
mink
and who's kind of like this you know
very modern like young girls probably
like 18 or 19 or something like that so
she starts acting really weird and
everybody thinks that oh the goddess
baiyan is now like choosing her like to
be the next shaman in the family but
then as the you know as it goes on maybe
that's not who is possessing her so i
kind of like
i kind of like that was a little bit
different like the possession angle but
coming from a culture where shamans like
allow themselves to be possessed
by berries but but then like in this
situation it's kind of like well she's
still possessed but maybe who we think
is possessing or is not possessing her
maybe this is like really bad
so
that so i liked that aspect of it um and
i like that it was done like a
mockumentary but i don't know if it
brought enough new to the table
to really be that kind of standout
because i mean yeah because it reminded
me like i said parts of it reminded me
of the whaling the fact that it was a
mockumentary reminded me a little bit
particularly the end reminded me like a
little bit of wreck um and it reminded
me like a lot of um a lot of the kind of
like exorcism movies even though there
was you know a thai flavor to it because
it's not set in
uh you know the christian world although
some of the characters are christians i
thought it was samey asian horror if you
ask me
yeah and well again it kind of bummed me
out because i thought
well though i mean the whaling which i'm
actually going to do a review on one of
these days because the whaling was so
[ __ ] good i mean the whaling was
really good and this kind of had aspects
of that even though the whaling is not
you know found footage or anything like
that this one is a mockumentary found
footage um
and you know and i don't know there were
aspects of it i liked i really liked the
acting i really liked honestly i kind of
liked
the first part of it more because it
went into
the lore like behind the shamans and
you know the you know her allowing the
goddess to take over and how explaining
like how that happened like how
how the goddess like gets in your body
and like makes you really sick
um until you do this ceremony where you
formally accept okay you can like be in
my body and then like the sickness will
go away or either that or you have to
say no [ __ ] this i don't want to do it
and then like you have to pass it on to
somebody else so that's basically what
happened so i kind of liked that and
then i liked the beginning of it with
mink where she was just starting to act
really weird like she and she was just
doing kind of like
um stuff that wasn't super over the top
like she would just kind of like stand
there and like stare really weirdly and
stuff see that kind of stuff is scarier
to me
um when it got toward the end it store
it sort of um went more in a kind of
like traditional
possessed person direction
um so i thought it wasn't as good then
you know what i mean like it wasn't as
original because you know obviously
possession movies we've all seen a
million of those and like everybody's
like all contorted and screaming and
their eyes are all white and everything
which you know so so i thought that it
was like a little less original as it
went on
uh so i i don't know i kind of thought
the first half of it was good but then
it kind of went off in
another one of those kind of movie
directions which is kind of a shame
because you know
it was a good concept
i don't know there's just too many damn
possession movies i feel like
you know what i'm saying this movie
there's a lot of possessions in the
single [ __ ] in in a single show it's
almost kind of like a zombie movie
yeah it's like [ __ ] man everybody was
getting possessed
there's a possession for you and it's
demon for you demon free david for you
everybody's [ __ ] possessed yeah so it
was that kind of thing so you know i i
like that there was like some cool [ __ ]
i liked that the one shot that that
actually stood out to me was like the
one dude that kept like running his head
into the wall which actually that looks
real i mean because like i said it's
done in um you know it's found footage
yeah some things look pretty real so
yeah so the special effect like
looked really real and that one like
particularly stood out the creepiest
[ __ ] is when the girl took the [ __ ]
dog and threw it in a damn hot pot and
[ __ ] burned it oh yeah that was
[ __ ] up too yeah cooked the dog in a
dry pot yeah that was yeah yeah i'd
forgotten about that that was like that
was pretty freaky and then she was like
eating it yeah you couldn't really see
it but you could hear it
yeah like when like when the film crew
because they they suspected that she was
getting up that mink was getting up in
the middle of the night and doing crazy
[ __ ] so they set up like secret night
vision cameras and so like the footage
when they showed it to her parents the
next day like look at all this crazy
[ __ ] that she's doing
um you know that was pretty creepy but
like i think it just went a little bit
over the top toward the end it was kind
of silly
yeah that's what that's what i meant
it's like i i kind of feel like the the
creepier stuff is the more low-key stuff
and i mean i know maybe that's just me
but i low-key [ __ ] is scarier to me than
over-the-top [ __ ] because if it goes too
far over the top with possessive stuff
then it just starts being like kind of
funny or yeah to me it's saying the same
same econ generic asian horror
the tone is kind of
not western
and to us it kind of silly i think
but it is what it is although i've seen
a lot of i've seen a lot of american and
european movies like possession ones
particularly that are
similar so you can tell that there's
like you know some mutual
influence going on yeah with that stuff
um interestingly this week i already
recorded it but i recorded a uh a review
of the taking of deborah logan which is
also kind of like a found footage
mockumentary thing and it's sort of a
possession story but
not a traditional possession story and
honestly i think that one was done much
better and like way creepier because it
was like way more and that was another
one that was kind of like low-key at the
beginning and that kind of went crazy at
the end but
but the crazy [ __ ] at the end of that
one was like way scarier to me than
this one was like i said this one seemed
like the end of it just seemed a lot
like
a lot like um
wreck that found footage movie which was
spanish i think and then they made like
an american remake called quarantine
which i haven't seen
um but it's just you know it's all like
that green night vision camera type [ __ ]
at the end and like i said everybody's
getting possessed and doing crazy [ __ ]
and screaming and contorting and
everything like that so
i don't know this i i kind of wish that
we could stop making possession poopies
for a little while let that [ __ ] rest
well it's just well it's getting to a
point where it's going where
it's going where a few years ago zombie
movies where i know people are still
making zombie movies stop it but um you
know what i mean it's i'm not saying you
have to stop it forever just
let it rest yeah just let it rest for a
little give some other monsters a chance
for grey's sake i mean you know so i i
don't know maybe they're not making as
many zombie movies nowadays as they were
because i do kind of see you know i do
kind of see now you're seeing stuff like
when it goes and stuff like that which
is cool because those are like
unrepresented monsters but
i now i kind of feel like so many like
[ __ ] possession movies man seriously
yeah i mean you know i guess it's the
same thing as like a zombie movie it's
easy to do just have somebody like
strapped to a bed screaming yeah
obscenities and
and doing their backup and [ __ ] like
that and it's like bingo we got a
possession about me you know what i mean
so i i don't know i i guess it's the
same thing because it's like cheap and
whatever
but um you know that's probably all i
got to say but i don't want to ruin it
for people want to watch it like it
seems like people on the shutter like
are digging it and stuff but and like i
said it's good it's just
um i think it was creepier like the
first half of it was creepier when it
was more low-key and there was more of
like a mystery i mean it wasn't a
mystery because you knew she was
possessed by something but
i don't know like the first part of it
was like way creepier and then when it
got past the point where
where you saw all the footage of her
like doing the crazy [ __ ] in the house
like eating the dog and everything um
you know then after that it just got too
over the top
what was that other time movie we
reviewed that was actually awesome the
pool that was tired that was a time
movie right yeah but it didn't have
[ __ ] possessions and [ __ ] no the time
well the pool was basically just got a
goddamn swimming pool yeah he's just
trapped in a pool and there's an
alligator in there yeah like or a
crocodile it was an excellent movie well
it was just it was very simple and like
i said there were really no supernatural
elements to it
um you know i mean in general i like a
lot of asian horror films and like you
know like i said i brought up the
whaling which was i think the same
producer as this one and that movie was
awesome like i love that and you know
how much we love korean horror i mean
korean horror ever every single korean
horror movie i've seen has been like
you know very very good to excellent
uh lately you know what i mean
and uh so
you know so this one was just kind of
like i said it was good but
it i didn't get bored like and even
though it's like really long and it
didn't seem long but
at the end i was kind of like well i
don't know i've seen a bunch of other
ones like that it just kind of seems
there wasn't enough different in it to
really kind of get me all excited about
it but you know what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do
not much well do you have anything that
you would like to talk about no not
really i thought i thought the movie was
sammy kind of generic
yeah it's like i said i agree but you
know the first half was interesting yeah
like but i don't know it just kind of
went that way i wouldn't recommend this
one
probably not no although some people
might like it i don't know but yeah you
never know
but uh you know and like i said it's
also found footage which
i'm not a huge fan of that either
although i've seen a lot of good ones
but that's it's not usually something
that i'm all that excited about i'm just
like oh found footage okay but you know
what are you gonna do so anyway um i
know this has been kind of short
but yeah that's all right
we're just being truthful about this one
yeah i mean and we'll be back tomorrow
talking about stuff probably if we have
time to watch anything tonight tonight
we got to watch um
the the patreon poll that we had for the
movie review the movie is actually a
series like an old 1980 british series
hammer house of horror which is 13
episodes so we got to start watching
that later tonight
all right we'll just cut this off also
tomorrow we might go see halloween kills
right yeah yeah
i mean maybe
no no no i gotta go uh i gotta go up to
the [ __ ] loan office oh that's right
that's right so yeah so we might have to
wait until later in the week to do that
one yeah um maybe we'll go see it
tuesday
or we could see it tonight i guess i
don't know what's one day
gonna get something to eat man i'm
starving me too god man it's gonna
sunday's gonna be crowded down there
sunday night probably yeah yeah i
haven't eaten since
noon yesterday let's go get some
dominoes
she's up the street i want to yeah i
want like a sandwich or something like
that well we could like order for pickup
and then go pick it up i'm just going to
pick some up
so yeah uh so yeah sorry this has been
kind of short but like if you're under
asian horror by all means check it out
it's on shutter um i didn't love it but
you know your mileage may vary but it
was good it was worth watching
uh your mileage may vary so we'll be
back tomorrow talking about whatever
whatever we whatever we if we watch a
movie or maybe we'll remember we we did
the food shows for a while and then we
stopped doing those
yeah yeah well we've been busy that's
true right that's true and you couldn't
think of any food to talk about but wait
i don't know we'll think of something
so yeah so thanks for dropping by and
hanging out with us we're going to go
stuff our faces because i'm starving
so we'll see you guys tomorrow